yep that's me drinking fermented horses
milk
I bet you're wondering how I got here
let me tell you
it started a bit ago when I was making a
Mongolian stew called Bonton for an
episode about hangover meals around the
world
the girl who submitted the dish her name
is Hulan from Mongolia started talking
about this specific drink our favorite
alcohol into you need to drink is beer
and sometimes fermented mesh milk and
it's called Eric so in this video we are
going to do two things first we are
going to travel to outer Mongolia to
learn all about this amazing drink and
then because I was able to get my hands
on some we are going to do a taste test
so let's start by leaving my living room
welcome to Mongolia where there might be
more animals than people locals here
make traditional Eric the process has
remained largely untouched since the
13th century
[Music]
foreign
can be a reliable source of protein fat
vitamins a c e and D in the summer
months many Mongolians actually drink
Eric as a substitute for meals so
to make it fresh Mare's milk is filtered
and then poured into a large cowhide Sac
called the kukur it is then stirred with
a combination of lactic acid bacteria
and yeast with a wooden Masher
repeatedly over one or two days
foreign
because of its fermentation which can
give Eric an alcohol content of over two
percent that is similar to a light beer
it also has some expected side effects
Beyond just its nutritional value
foreign
[Music]
can have a slightly sour taste that some
Mongolians think might take some getting
used to
um
I'm sold and I'm excited to try this
Eric was actually not easy to find I
searched the city but ultimately I found
it online and had it shipped directly to
my house from Mongolia
so we are going to do a taste test I
have three different levels of Eric
starting with the most expensive down to
instant packets and I'm going to taste
them all I think that we should
obviously start with the most expensive
you know you don't want to start with
the cheapest for your first rodeo
[Music]
cheers
oh
that has a very interesting flavor the
taste of this feels very
grassy almost there's very much this
element of nature in this and there's a
sourness that you get from the
fermentation but it's different from the
idea of a kefir if you've ever had that
the sourness of this tastes a little
more expired
it's an acquired taste I will give you
that
I will give you that all right let's try
the next one so this is level two
[Music]
this one is actually maybe a little bit
easier to drink first impressions is
that this one was a lot thinner
this one just tastes a little bit more
like sour yogurt that you've just put a
bunch of water in and so I'm finding the
flavor to be like a little easier for
the third one we are doing the cheapest
version which is just an instant packet
so this is powdered fermented Mare's
milk that I'm putting into lukewarm
water
cheers
well I will say that this is actually
the easiest to drink because I wasn't
really sure how much water to put in so
this might be the most watered down of
all of them this kind of tastes like
cheese milk
I think that there is a very real and
understandable tendency for people if
they are introduced to a food that is
very much outside of what is culturally
accepted where they are to think like ew
or to be scared of it for me this whole
experience was really improved from
learning and really seeing the practice
in its culture and it made me a lot more
excited to try it and I think that it
really helped me appreciate what I was
trying even if I didn't truly love it
[Music]
I would love to know if this is
something that you would ever be open to
trying let me know in the comments until
then I am going to leave a link in the
description to where you can find all of
these milks just you know in case you're
curious cheers
[Music]